hi I'm Rob cubby and I'm the editor of
National Geographic calm I'm happy today
to be able to show you the new website
that we've built here you'll find new
features Daily News photo of the day and
access to our archive of animal travel
and adventure content one of the things
you'll notice as you scroll across the
top of the menu items is something we're
calling the fly out the fly out stays
with you wherever you're going in
National Geographic and it gives you a
rich visual window to the material
that's inside that section one of my
favorite things about the new site is an
exciting new presentation for photo of
the day click through c1 c2 keep going
it's absolutely spectacular we hope
you'll come back often and see the
photographs that we're featuring
National Geographic news brings you
features every day from archaeology to
science to space to the world of animals
in nature that we think is both
entertaining and lightning and fun on
the web in photography we also have the
daily dozen which is a collection of
your photographs selected by the editors
of National Geographic magazine we have
over 80,000 users in my shot which is
our photo community they've contributed
over 700,000 photographs which they can
share and rate and comment on you'll
find Interactive's on our site that are
as engaging as anything you've seen on
the web
we have a new video player coming that
expresses the depth of the video that we
have to offer which is nothing short of
astonishing over the next few weeks will
make it easier for you to upload your
photos and videos and share them with
your friends on sites like Facebook and
Twitter come join the adventure on
National Geographic calm we've got
something new for you every day